e niente
qualcuno m'ha dato ragazzi e Ben
ritrovati se non date sto facendo solo
video dove parlo e perché non so che
cazzo no scherzo la vita che oggi doveva
uscire un altro video e non è uscito
perché ci sono state delle problematiche
non posso dirvi che video è perché fa
parte di sorprese che arrivano tra poco
Porco demonio non posso dirvi niente se
non tamponare ma raccontandovi una cosa
molto divertente non per me ma per voi
altro se vedete che zoom ogni tanto
perché non sto usando la videocamera ma
sto usando la webcam questo perché ho
dei brufoli che quella webcam non si
vede tra l'altro questa settimana non so
quando e non so quando verrà pubblicato
sto video però dovrebbe uscire Sons of
the forest che il seguito
e the forest 2 però il capitolo è un
prequel Non vedo l'ora di giocarlo Porca
vacca nel mentre vi racconto un aneddoto
che alcuni di voi sono in meno culture
si ricorderanno che per me è stato un
po' un mezzo incubo adesso lo racconto
c'è stata una volta anzi ci sarà più di
una volta dove Ehm io ho in realtà
bestemmiato in un video mi è successo
Adesso ve ne racconto una situazione
perché io ovviamente nei video non
bestemmio Allora io non sono credente
Tra l'altro Vabbè non sono credente
diciamo che a me ogni tanto una vita
privata non sono un bestemmiatore
seriale ma non sono Veneto però mi
capita ogni tanto di lanciare il porcone
non lo faccio anche pubblicamente anche
per rispetto di chi invece Cristiano e
quindi io porto rispetto però mi è
capitato un paio di volte due o tre
volte che è una bestemmia scappasse
fuori quando tu fai un video al giorno
sostanzialmente capita molto spesso che
magari escano delle cose che non
dovrebbero uscire perché ovviamente
quando tu registri un video al giorno i
tempi Registra un video al giorno cosa
fai tu registri poi monti il video
quindi 3-4 ore in montaggio dipende dal
video e poi il video viene pubblicato il
giorno dopo questo tutti i giorni poi è
subentrato Giampiero che ha fatto la
parte di montaggio invece registravo e
basta quando ho montato io i miei video
non è mai uscita una bestemmia quando
non ho montato io i miei video
Pensa che l'ho pagato pure Giampiero
stavo giocando a little nightmares 2 era
non mi ricordo che episodio il secondo
il terzo E sostanzialmente a me ogni
tanto quando quando registro quando
registravo i Gameplay mi capita alle
volte di ridire una frase No perché la
ridico più volte perché magari l'ho
detta male mi mi impappino no per dirla
bene Magari stop il video e la ridico
sei un qualcosa di importante Ok capita
c'era una cosa che io non riuscivo a
dire e quindi l'ho detta tre o quattro
volte e alla quarta volta ho lanciato un
porcone adesso non mi ricordo se ce
l'avevo con ehm col nostro Signore
oppure con la mamma era esattamente
questa parte qua qui ragazzi in questo
preciso punto io dico questo non devo
più rapire le persone bravo questo punto
è stato ripetuto più volte perché io non
riuscivo a dire non devo più rapire le
persone la quarta volta che non riuscivo
più a dirlo non devo più non devo pu-
Non non devo più Porco Dio questa scena
questa scena in particolare è stata
messa tutta dentro il video Cioè tipo 30
secondi o anche di più 40 una quarantina
di secondi tutti i am Cat dove io
continuo a dire la stessa fra cui si
vede tutta la scena in cui io tento di
dire questa frase più volte con annessa
bestemmia tutta una parte che Giampiero
non ha tagliato Cosa succede il video va
online io non me ne sono accorto perché
in genere quando Giampiero monta i video
e poi li guardo ma non riuscivo a
riguardarli tutti perché con un video al
giorno magari dovevo fare delle cose non
riuscivo però Giampiero che deve fare
solo quello monti il video lo riguardi A
quanto pare no non ha fatto questa cosa
è uscito tutto un minuto ancut quindi è
uscita una bestemmia il video esce tipo
all'una e mezza come solito ero in
cucina mi stavo preparando da mangiare a
un certo punto mi arriva in dm un mese
io ma grazie a Dio ho aperto i dm Ma
grazie a Dio mi arriva un messaggio di
un fan che mi dice Occhio Favi che al
minuto non mi ricordo 15 16 eh C'è una
bestemmia io cosa faccio io prendo il
video e lo tolgo o viene tutto perché se
andate a vedere il prezzo della
bestemmia di base YouTube a modo di
tagliare un pezzo no perché tu puoi
togliere i pezzi andiamo a togliere il
video però lì per lì mi sono cagato
nelle mutande questa cosa è successa
quando è uscito di Twilight questa cosa
è successa quando è uscita Little
nightmares non bestemmierò proprio
ripetuto quindi non mi ricordo se c'era
già il tool per togliere i pezzi di
video però ho tolto tutto quanto il
video ho chiamato Giampiero e gli ho
detto che porco vai Ti prego tagliamo
quella parte di passami i video che lo
carico e poi l'ho ricaricato senza
panico perché succede una cosa succede
che avevano già campionato il pezzo
c'erano campionato il pezzo della
bestemmia Quindi cosa succede quel pezzo
in particolare inizia a spuntare fuori
su Tik Tok su YouTube proprio il pezzo
della bestemmia perché la gente la
campionato iniziava a caricare video con
su scritto Favij bestemmia panico cosa
ovviamente altamente illegale e
denunciabile tutto denunciabile però
essendo tutti ragazzini quindi io non è
che posso lo posso fare Però questo
questo problematica poi Grava sui
genitori perché giustamente loro non si
rendono conto di quello che stanno
facendo ho cercato di mediare senza far
partire denuncia a destra manca Okay mi
sono armato di differenza e con
Giampiero ovviamente che per risolvere
l'accaduto mi è venuto incontro è ogni
video che veniva veniva caricato perché
venivano caricati ogni 5 minuti veniva
caricato un video veniva
sistematicamente buttato giù Ok quindi
uno caricava un video Favij Pam andato
giù questa cosa si è ripetuta per un
paio di giorni ovunque su Tik Tok su
YouTube ho cercato di non denunciare ma
di contenere è la cosa ha fortunatamente
ha funzionato qua mi ha fatto capire tra
l'altro quanto è difficile fermare un
contenuto virale Cioè se qualcuno in
possesso di un file di una foto di un
file video fermare la viralità del del
video stesso è difficilissimo può essere
caricato a manetta quindi per fermare la
per contenere la viralità dell'accaduto
siamo stati davanti al computer per
giorni questa è stata il grandissimo
aneddoto sulla bestemmia che è andata
più virale in assoluto che è stata
questa qua che momenti raga che momenti
epici che ho vissuto Questo era un video
era quella volta che bestemmiare
sostanzialmente non può che non facevo
il video tipo quella volta che volevo
una roba con disimpegno perché purtroppo
è saltato un video che non vi posso dire
un video molto carino che doveva uscire
che uscirà comunque nei prossimi giorni
Non sarà il prossimo perché ragazzi il
prossimo video Fino a prova contraria
poi non so se succederà qualcosa al 99%.
sarà sols of the forest Quindi uscirà il
gameplay di the forest quello nuovo Non
perdetevelo perché sarà incredibile
Quindi ragazzi Spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto iscrivetevi al canale lasciate
un bel mi piace e noi come sempre ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi